سفينه الصحافه التقليديه اخذه بالغرق شيئا
فشيئا بل يتكسر جليدها على منصات التواصل
المشتعله تقرير لمعهد رويترز لدراسه صحافه
اكد تراجع نسبه الحاصلين على الاخبار من
مواقع الكترونيه او تطبيقات بعشر نقاط منذ
2018 اكد الى الشباب اهتماما اكبر بمشاهير
وبمؤثرين وشخصيات معروفه على وسائل
التواصل مقارنه بصحفيين تيك توك هو الاسرع
نموا بين وسائل التواصل وفق التقرير اذ
يستخدمه للاخبار عشرون في المئه ممن
ينتمون للفئه العمريه بين 18 و 24 عاما اي
بزياده قدرها خمس نقاط مئويه عن العام
الماضي ابدى 48% من المشاركين اهتماما
بالاخبار من الاساس بعد ان سجل عام 2017
63 في المئه منهم فيما فضل اقل من ثلث
المشاركين اختيار القصص الاخباريه لهم من
خلال الخوارزميات اكثر من ان يخ لهم رؤساء
تحرير او صحفيون هذا وانخفضت ثقه اكثر من
56% من المشتركين بالاخبار حيث ابدو قلقه
من عدم القدره على التمييز بين الاخبار
الحقيقيه والزائفه ارتكز تقرير على مسح
عبر الانترنت شارك فيه حوالي 94 الف بالخ
في 46 سوقا من بينها الولايات المتحده
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات